congressman mark green Republican of
Tennessee sits on the House Homeland
Security a committee joins us via Skype
congressman always good to have you what
do you make of these restrictions right
now and those traveling from Brazil
I would suspect it but they're more
could follow where we going with this
healing well Neil first thanks for
having me on the show and I think it's
expected I mean you look at the counts
that are coming to us from Brazil three
hundred and plus thousand cases twenty
two thousand deaths there's a university
down there that predicts that it could
be twelve times that their ability to
track information is different than our
ability I mean if you do twelve times
that or even ten times that that's
200,000 plus deaths so it's appropriate
and it's very consistent that the
president would put this restriction on
you know we're watching their curve very
closely watching the other curves really
all across the world and it's
appropriate at this time to kind of hold
off on a non-us citizen travel from
Brazil we already know that visits from
China and points far east of course are
already in danger of being you know cut
down and and very very low going forward
you see anything to to change that or do
you advocate that now since it seems to
be over the worst of it we can entertain
allowing more into this country or or
things so bad now now it's not the time
to consider I think we just have to take
into consideration
everyone's curve just like here in the
United States we're sort of treating
states differently New York clearly is
in a different place in terms of
reopening and travel than Tennessee is
and I think we can do that in terms of
the countries overseas and our allies
and friends we want to we want to open
up as quickly as we can but just it
really depends on where they are in
their curve and if then if they're in an
exponential growth phase like Brazil is
we probably need to stop travel do you
wonder about this relationship we have
with the Chinese we're gonna be getting
into this a little more in the show but
the one issue that's come up is that the
more we threatened to crack down on how
the Chinese are cracking down on Hong
Kong the worse it's gonna get between us
certainly financially
the Chinese have little reason to stick
to a deal they promise to honor now that
could change but but that it does get
kind of out of control your thoughts
well we're already in a great power
competition with China and if you use
the dime paradigm diplomatic
informational military and economic
we've been an economic warfare almost
with China for many years and and we
didn't even know it the case of Motorola
is an excellent example seventeen
billion dollar company they share their
IP information with Huawei they undercut
them with government subsidies from
China and the companies basically
scrapped in 2011 for 900 million dollars
fifty thousand Americans lose their job
two or three billion dollars off the GDP
of the United States that's what fuels
our military that's what allows us to
provide national security so I mean
there's been a great power competition
for a very long time
the with Xi Jingping it's like it's gone
exponential and it's informational cyber
hacking all this stuff so the way
they've handled kovat only icing on the
cake to a big problem if China wants a
great relationship with the United
States they've got to start acting like
a friend and you know the way they
handled Co vid is just more concerning
and their response to our response to
that is even worse all right we'll watch
it closely congressman thank you